revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 hoy ya estamos a jueves casi
finalizando una semana más de programa
conmigo en el estudio y hasta rosa pérez
masdéu pero esta vamos a abrir entonces
esta revista de prensa con la portada el
espectador en colombia que lleva tres
temas claves por un lado como avanzamos
el inicio el paro nacional de hace un
año exactamente raúl buenos días y es
que wii hoy se cumple un año tal y como
titula el espectador en uno de estos
temas destacados de la portada de que
pues arrancó este estallido social que
recordemos inicialmente fue contra la
propuesta de la reforma tributaria
presentada por el gobierno de iván duque
pero que finalmente pues acabó siendo
una protesta de prácticamente dos meses
consecutivos contra la profunda
desigualdad no del sistema
socioeconómico de colombia y de los
pocos instrumentos que hay para paliar
estas desigualdades y básicamente hoy
distintos medios colombianos destacan
qué
múltiples convocatorias tanto en bogotá
en la capital como en distintos puntos
del país para volver a arrancar un poco
y recordar estas protestas y estas
reivindicaciones de cara a estas
elecciones presidenciales a la vuelta de
la esquina raúl y bueno básicamente
en el tiempo podemos ver un poco cuáles
son las convocatorias de hoy que en
principio irán hasta este domingo día 1
de mayo día internacional del trabajador
así es rosa y por otro lado como decimos
que son 3 vamos ahora a la segunda la
audiencia en la gp la jurisdicción
especial para la paz en colombia por el
caso de los 'falsos positivos' a quien
salpica bueno es raúl vamos a pasar por
encima de este titular ahora y loa
profundizaremos en el siguiente punto
pero básicamente el espectador dice
faltó verdad y es una cita de pues los
familiares que estaban presentes estos
dos días el martes y ayer en ocaña norte
de santander en esta primera audiencia
de reconocimiento de responsabilidades
en el caso conocido como falsos
positivos que récord el asesinato de
jóvenes civiles a manos de militares del
ejército de colombia que hizo pasar sus
cadáveres por los de guerrilleros caídos
en combate esto sobre todo durante la
primera década de los años 2000 bajo la
presidencia de álvaro uribe ya que pues
vamos a centrarnos precisamente en el
precisamente rosa hablando de álvaro
uribe el espectador titula revés
jurídico un tema que también destaca el
país de españa y también desgrana la
silla vacía exactamente porque ayer pues
una jueza de aquí de bogotá carmen elena
ortiz decidió no cerrar el proceso
judicial contra el ex presidente uribe
abierto en la corte suprema de justicia
de aquí de colombia por supuesta
manipulación de testigos y de hecho la
fiscalía pedía la preclusión de esta
causa una causa que el país se titula la
más importante de colombia porque
precisamente recordemos un poco de qué
va y es que lo que tuvo lugar ayer el
fallo de esta jueza no va sobre sí
es culpable o no de esta manipulación de
testigos y no lo que dice es que hay
suficientes indicios como para que la
investigación siga abierta y esta
investigación hace referencia al momento
en que el senador de izquierdas iván
cepeda denunció ante el congreso de
colombia uno de los supuestos vínculos
entre el expresidente uribe y el
paramilitarismo en ese momento uribe
decidió denunciar por la vía penal al
senador y supuestamente es en el marco
de estas denuncias penales cuando habría
tenido lugar esta manipulación de
testigos vamos a ver por qué este
proceso va a seguir durante años raúl
así es de rosa y vamos a centrarnos
ahora en esta audiencia pública de la gp
por el caso de los falsos positivos para
explicar ahondar más en este tema
efectivamente y hemos primero querido
seleccionar la portada del espectador no
de hoy sino de ayer tras este primer día
de audiencia de la gp con este titular
no es tan impactante y tan histórico
asesinamos a inocentes declaraciones de
mí después retirados que reconocen su
responsabilidad en este caso de los
'falsos positivos'
también el tiempo no evidentemente lleva
pues un poco la misma cuestión y cita al
general coronado que dijo pasaré a la
historia como el primer general
condenado por circunstancias que nunca
debieron ocurrir y también agradeció a
las víctimas a los familiares de estos
jóvenes presentes ayer y antes de ayer
en esta audiencia de lage por su
persistencia en a buscar la justicia y
hacer así un país mejor pero raúl es que
este tema llega incluso al 'new york
times' así es rosa que dice entonces
este diario estadounidense sobre ese
tema tan delicado y también tan tan
cruel no como ellos decían también a la
mamá de las de las víctimas yo maté a su
hijo un carácter un frente frente que no
debe ser nada fácil para ninguno de los
dos
exacto pues el 'new york times' por un
lado hace una descripción un poco
fáctica diciendo oficiales retirados
retirados admitieron haber organizado
ejecuciones extrajudiciales
particularmente esto diez militares y un
civil que reconocieron sus
responsabilidades en estos crímenes
reconocieron particularmente haber
estado implicados en 120 asesinatos de
jóvenes civiles pero estalló solamente
como dice new york times' es la punta
del iceberg de un caso que según lage la
jurisdicción especial para la paz quien
investiga este caso en marco en el marco
no de su creación a raíz de los acuerdos
de paz entre el estado y las farc de
2016 estima que habría unos a 6400 dos
casos de 'falsos positivos'
por otro lado
cita también el 'new york times' pues
digamos otras otras declaraciones de los
militares déjame leerte la del cabo del
ejército néstor guillermo gutiérrez que
dijo y hoy quiero que el mundo sepa que
eran campesinos que yo como miembro de
la fuerza pública asesine cobardemente
le arrebate la ilusión a sus hijos le
desgarra el corazón a sus madres por una
presión por unos resultados por unos
falsos resultados por tener contento a
un gobierno bueno eso no en los detalles
hicieron puedes haber cambiado las
vestimentas de estos jóvenes de sus
cadáveres la documentación y pues
solamente insistir en un detalle que
también enfatiza new york times' y es
que las víctimas dicen sabemos que
detrás de ustedes vienen personas muy
grandes y en sus camisetas esta frase
pues que ya se ha convertido en un grito
de guerra de quien dio la orden así es
rosa gracias entonces a por toda la
información no vemos mañana viernes con
más revista de prensa pasamos a saludar
a nuestro primer invitado el día